Speaker 1: So, Hello!
Speaker 1: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Active Inference Lab
and to the first Active Inference Gueststream.
I'm here with our special guest,
Majid Beni.
And we're just really honored and excited
to be hearing your presentation.
We're going to be having a
about 30 minute presentation
on whatever you'd like to be speaking on.
And then I'm going to be
collecting questions from a live chat
and then relaying them to you.
Speaker 1: And it was already just fun
to talk to you right before we started.
So thanks again, Majid, and take it away.
Go for it.
Speaker 1: All right.
Hello. Thank you very much.
I'm very excited to and I thank you
very much for giving me the chance
to present a part of my work. So
I'm basically beginning.
To speak what I've.
Speaker 1: Done, the parts of my work.
On our pre-interview principles.
Speaker 1: So I will try.
To share my screen. Right.
Now because I'm a great believer
in extended mind.
And you could do anything
without having my screen share
so you won't be able to see
my screen yet.
It looks perfect. Thank you. Perfect.
So I'm basically going to present
the parts of my.
Work in a recent paper, and since it was
critical, it's very critical.
I know you see more and more anything.
And the structure.
Speaker 1: Of this talk is quite straightforward.
So I briefly.
Speaker 1: Very.
Speaker 1: Briefly and with a very broad brush with
the speaker will create the principle.
And Marco, we had modernism.
So I gloss over.
Speaker 1: That technical stuff because.
Speaker 1: For one thing,
I'm a philosopher and I'm not very.
Speaker 1: Well versed in these technical
aspects of everything.
I'm going to present the core of my work,
which is about scientific models.
Speaker 1: So after that.
Speaker 1: I speak briefly about scientific models
and scientific modeling
and philosophy of science,
but coming from a background
of philosophy of science as. What
it is, the main.
Speaker 1: Part of my contribution
to this literature, being educated, to
look at it through the lens
of philosophy, of science
and usual scientific representation.
Then I'm going to
describe
microbial models
as some sort of scientific models that.
Scrutinize their relationship with
their target models in the real world.
Speaker 1: And see whether any of these.
Speaker 1: Descriptions of the relationship
between microbial models
and their target system
could support more coffee and.
Movies.
And briefly, at the end, I will.
Ask to. Evaluate.
Christopher and colleagues attempt
at developing more appropriate models
of along the lines of the structure.
So So most probably, you know, more.
Speaker 1: Than we have created the critical
and predicted process.
The idea has been.
Speaker 1: Reintroduced to science, but
the roots of this idea
seems to be quite old.
But it has been.
Around refused to restore to science
by corporate and colleagues.
Speaker 1: And this is all based.
Speaker 1: On a simple and subtle idea.
So generally
it. Provides
a framework that explains
how a biological system explores
the random and unpredictable fluctuation
in its external environment
and can restrict itself to occupying
a limited number of the state
and therefore therefore survive
in some recognizable form.
So in order to be able.
Speaker 1: To resist those dispersing
the force of the environment,
the organism has to, in a nutshell,
have to keep.
The amount. Of its free energy.
Speaker 1: Low and predicted.
Processing some sort of material
application, indicating that then applied
to the brain of some broken system
such as yourselves.
In all creativity of minimizing.
Rain, you could be specified in terms of
minimization, of prediction error.
So there are very few models in the brain
and through a process of.
A top down.
Process, the brain
or the organism, and order to.
Apply these models.
To reality
or at least check them
against the reality, against the evidence
that receives from the external.
World.
And when.
Speaker 1: There is a discrepancy in zeros to.
Somehow revise.
The models updated model or at least
make changes to the environment,
so there is.
Speaker 1: Some sort of action by the.
Governmental action or overt action.
But acting. In France is the.
Speaker 1: Other side.
Minimization of prediction, error.
Speaker 1: And freestone and colleagues.
Made a freestone devil of free energy
principle into a fascinating theory
of consciousness
in terms of temporal richness
or temporal depths of generating models.
Speaker 1: So not only some organism can
minimize.
Speaker 1: Their creativity.
Speaker 1: And. Optimize
the representation of the environment,
they could also some hope for some sort
of foresight or prediction of.
The possible.
Speaker 1: Outcomes of their action
in the environment and.
Speaker 1: It seems that this.
Speaker 1: Capacity is somewhat tied with you.
Speaker 1: With conscious.
Speaker 1: Progresses or consciousness.
And of course there this idea of Markov
blankets.
Due to the appeal.
Introduced them I think in 1980s.
There are some sort of Bayesian rules
which.
Speaker 1: Could help.
Us to make a distinction
between cognition and the going forward
to cognition or independence between
internal and external spaces.
So on the literature
itself, free creativity.
Principle has been quite. Flourishing.
Quite a number of.
Scientists philosophers.
Have.
Contributed to developing this literature
and among the philosophers of up
to just to mention a few.
Speaker 1: Of our great people who.
Speaker 1: Contributed to such a
proposal and are shown.
Speaker 1: By lively and
even people who are coming from a.
Background of philosophy or science
such as Mr.
Fine. Art, but have contributed.
Speaker 1: To this rich literature.
But what what's interesting is that.
The free energy creative code.
Has not been developed.
Into some sort of.
Metaphysical.
Speaker 1: Cases of cognition
or consciousness or brain.
So as far as I can see, this
paper.
Speaker 1: Which is the target paper of my paper,
incentives for Cartesian
biology to Markov motives,
there is a sort
of a Cristiano is an observer.
As far as I can see.
It is the main work.
The main paper.
That actually contributed to
this painting or to the metaphysical
implications.
Of the free energy principle,
which is the main paper,
as far as I can see, that.
Try to develop free.
Speaker 1: Energy principle into some sort of.
Metaphysical tissue.
Speaker 1: Self-Consciousness
and I think that for this reason
alone, the paper deserves attention.
And I'm a great admirer of for
I usually do not engage with.
Speaker 1: Reviewing or criticizing single papers.
But this paper attracted my attention
and interest because I think.
That it is so even before.
Is people such as, for example,
Christian Impulse and themselves
trying to develop a free energy
principle into a theory of consciousness
that provides. A point to.
Cartesian.
Speaker 1: Do all these souls to.
Speaker 1: Try to do so.
But as far as I can see, here.
Speaker 1: For the first time created,
the principle has having developed. Into
a very well-defined metaphysical.
Speaker 1: Texts, which is modernism.
Speaker 1: So the main point here
is that I'm more sympathetic.
Speaker 1: To the goal of this paper,
to the objective of this paper
that at times the paper may indicate.
Speaker 1: And what I'm going. To say.
Is mainly
aimed to
invoke.
Speaker 1: Provoke the brain of the principles to
develop this Markov in motives mean into.
A slightly
better, I call it well-supported.
Account of consciousness,
metaphysical account of consciousness.
Speaker 1: And I'm going. To look at this issue.
And so regardless of philosophy,
of statements to see the relationship
between my career blankets
and their environment
as some sort of relation between
scientific models, because more program
or some sort of scientific models
and I'm going to.
Speaker 1: Argue for.
Speaker 1: Provide some argumentation sort of.
Speaker 1: To draw a connection.
Speaker 1: Between.
Markov yet
models on the one and the target system
on the other and so-called.
Consciousness
that appears to this relationship.
Speaker 1: Could be put.
Speaker 1: Into some sort of monism,
which is a metaphysical search.
So I'm going to look at this issue
through the lens
of philosophy of science.
And unfold.
The implication of the implication
for Markov in modernism.
Speaker 1: So the taste is
itself Markov and modernism.
Speaker 1: Is quite straightforward.
Speaker 1: I have highlighted.
The part of it for you here.
So the thesis is, is that fundamentally.
There is.
Only one type of thing and only one type.
Of irreversible progress.
And Markov in Black
has formed the calculus of belief,
which is not only a nice scientific
mathematical model of consciousness,
but also provides
a clear metaphysical statement.
And I can shed light on.
Speaker 1: Current philosophical debates.
So the highlighted only. Two parts that.
So it is this is the statement
of North Korean modernism.
And the red.
Box indicates that.
How. Forcefully
the theory has been spelled
metaphysical term.
So there is only one type of team
is a strong metaphysical physics.
And this is something that has been also
stated in Freecell and colleagues paper
so. And here I highlighted.
Speaker 1: Another part of the same phrase
which indicates that.
Speaker 1: This is a statement of.
Speaker 1: Consciousness.
Speaker 1: On the basis of more programed models
is not just the most scientific.
Speaker 1: Or mathematical model of consciousness,
but also provides
and it's a physical statement.
So the main question here is this
how could Holcomb
that we could build Holcomb?
Holcomb that.
We could read off a metaphysical tissues.
Speaker 1: On the.
Speaker 1: Basis of our scientific models
of the phenomenal
scientific
mathematical models of phenomena.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to
ask this question.
Speaker 1: As I say.
Speaker 1: Through the lens of philosophy of science
to see what's the.
Speaker 1: Relation between.
I think that this basic.
Question of the recipe of science,
what's the relation
between scientific models
and their target system.
They are significantly on.
Speaker 1: The claim of Markov and.
Is which tries to.
Speaker 1: Develop some sort.
Of a strong metaphysical tests
on the basis of dispersion
modeling to scientific model, which are.
More blanket
so this is an.
Insight from philosophy of science.
And the insight has been.
I think, that.
Originally it has its roots in works of
Ronald Gary. And
Paul.
Churchland, for example.
Speaker 1: And a number of.
Boston for us and himself,
a number of important causes
for ourselves to be developing this idea.
Speaker 1: Of model.
Speaker 1: Based approach
to scientific theories in 1980s
and it has been recently
surveys.
Of. Research groups they work so Michael.
Weisberg and Rob.
Speaker 1: Manfred and Godfrey isms so.
Speaker 1: And the general idea is.
Speaker 1: That scientific practice
is basically consist
of model making making scientific models.
Speaker 1: And the thing is that so if you have
been engaging.
Speaker 1: In scientific practice just.
Do not.
Speaker 1: Directly engage in course.
Speaker 1: Of reading of the ideas.
From the future of war,
reading of the theory of the theories do.
Not just latch on to the word directing.
There is some sort.
Of representation
and representation of relation between
scientific theories, scientific models
and the work is.
Speaker 1: Being.
Speaker 1: Done.
Indirect so scientific
theories do not represent the features
of the work directly.
Speaker 1: The main thing here is that
of, quote, a few human factors.
Interfere through the process
of scientific representation,
so to name only a few.
For example, scientists interest
and explanatory goals and intentions.
Speaker 1: Play a role in how scientists.
Are constructing their scientific models.
And or use them to.
Speaker 1: Represent the features.
Of reality by scientific models and.
Speaker 1: Those of free, for example.
Among other people.
Explains, this process of indirect
representation.
Is quite sophisticated.
It includes several stages,
such as the notation or
designation, example, exemplification.
Speaker 1: Kingo and.
Speaker 1: Imputation.
So the main point.
Here, the take home point here is that.
Speaker 1: The relationship
between science models on life and.
Reality, on the other hand, or the target
system on the other hand, is quite.
Speaker 1: Sophisticated. It never.
Is straightforward.
Speaker 1: And there are three ways of so
remarkable that kids more and.
Models or just every shown scientific
tools in the model or told books that.
Speaker 1: Follow the model
or to represent the features of.
The world in the or.
Speaker 1: So I'm going to speak about three ways of
understanding Markov young models.
I'm beginning so
as the.
Speaker 1: Sketch that I showed earlier indicates.
By beginning with.
Speaker 1: Interpreting Markov, we had models
as physical or material models first.
Then as fictional models
and finally as mathematical models.
And disorder has been chosen
deliberately because.
I'm going from the knees to.
Like the reading of Markov Year models,
I'm going to the most likely
interpretation of Markov. We have models.
So I'm convinced that Markov.
Models could be understood. Theories
as some sort.
Speaker 1: Of mathematical models.
But I also consider other.
Speaker 1: Options because there are some sort
of textual evidence to support them.
So for example. We could
it is indeed possible.
Speaker 1: To understand Markov blankets
or Marco models as some sort of.
Physical.
Speaker 1: Models, material models,
for example, Crystal Stirling.
But to 20 1934 that.
The Marco.
Speaker 1: Blanket is not some statistical device
by which we could
or we use it to observe or model
the more the necessary attributes
of the universe.
That can be.
Carved into. Tables.
So at least to.
Speaker 1: A first approximation,
we would try to read this phrase
or the second phrase from the same paper.
It seems that.
For. Free energy
principle theories for free.
So for. Example.
Markov Blankets are actually features
of the reality themselves.
They are physical things.
There are real,
real things out there. And
so I think that it is not.
Speaker 1: Only Greece
that is advocating this reading.
I think it also.
I have seen.
Speaker 1: Similar phrases in, for example, recent
your introduction
to predictive processing and also the.
Speaker 1: All. And Freestone paper is seen to 26,
I think.
Speaker 1: So this is there is some textual.
Basis for understanding.
Markov Markov blankets as physical model.
But I think
and I think that this indication.
Speaker 1: This reference to Markov blankets
as physical things has to be taken with.
A grain of salt.
I do not think that there are.
Actually such things.
So if we, for example.
Open the.
Bread or. Open an.
Organic system,
I do. Not think that we can.
Speaker 1: Find anything
resembling a Marco Rubio blanket
or actually there is no blanket there.
There is no such physical thing.
But I could understand if a.
Speaker 1: Terrorist.
Could conceive of.
The target system as.
You could really include this.
Representational device.
But the point is that
even if we consider.
Speaker 1: Some concept that Marco blankets
Marco Rubio and models
are features of reality
or physical things that exist in the.
Speaker 1: World, even if we consider that
it doesn't follow that
reality itself.
Sure.
As the ontological
and material futures market.
But I think that it doesn't follow
that there is.
Speaker 1: The same
self, same ontological category
that includes both Marco Polo and.
Their target system.
And there is an. Example
that could. Demonstrate that.
So for example, there is the such thing
as a hydraulic home
model of economics.
So hydraulic foam is a physical object.
Speaker 1: And for erotic model to work, some.
Properties of economics
is the most be identified because.
It already. Properties of. The pole.
Speaker 1: It could be, for example,
exemplified
through the process of imputation.
We could.
Speaker 1: Ascribe.
Speaker 1: Or attribute some of the appropriate use
of the hydraulic pole
to the physical object.
Speaker 1: So sorry.
Speaker 1: To to ascribe
some of the properties of these reform
to the economic system
that is supposed to be represented.
But it doesn't follow that the.
Economical system and hydraulic pole,
which is a physical object.
Can be put.
Under the same ontological category
or material category.
So for example, he could already fall,
which is a physical object
is made of, for example,
a steel or plastic
or some some other matter ability
and it doesn't follow that economic sure.
As this.
Material.
Speaker 1: On to future.
So I simply put the
materialist.
Interpretation of Mark Markov
blanket aside.
Speaker 1: And proceed to consider.
Speaker 1: Remarkable.
That gives us a picture of models. So
and the main.
Speaker 1: Reason for this is that I assume that
if we for example, explore
with the actual grain of organism,
we couldn't find anything resembling.
A marble. Blanket inside the brains.
So we could interpret them as some.
Some sort of fictional objects and.
So then the fiction on these
and again, there are textual support.
For this. For example, Christo.
And colleagues say that
if it's if we look into the behavior.
Of creatures through the lenses.
Speaker 1: Of Markov models,
it may look as if it is acting
with the creatures, acting to minimize.
These particles are also, for example.
So this as.
A phrase, new categories.
Speaker 1: I think that is very important
in case that they do not think.
That there is such thing
as Markov blanketing the creature.
But it's look.
As if there is such thing.
And it has to be this.
Interpretation this picture values,
instrumentalist interpretation.
Speaker 1: Is gaining.
Momentum, as far as I can see.
So there are a number of other people,
such as Max Firearms and.
Various.
That are developing
some sort of fictionalized
and instrumentalist
interpretation of reinterpret principle.
But the thing is that
if you consider this.
Picture this interpretation. Of market.
Blanket or creator principle.
It follows that.
So if market.
Speaker 1: Blankets are used for fiction, we could.
End of
derive.
Speaker 1: Any sort of metaphysical conclusion
from them.
So from a fiction.
Speaker 1: So for.
Speaker 1: Example,
if you are studying Greek mythology.
Speaker 1: And assuming.
Speaker 1: That Greek
mythology is some sort of a fiction.
Speaker 1: You cannot derive any conclusion
about the nature.
Speaker 1: Of beauty
from what you read in a story from.
Greek mythology,
there are no metaphysical.
Conclusion to be drawn from.
Fictions.
Speaker 1: And stories.
And this is precisely the point
in invoking a fiction.
Speaker 1: Based approach for scientific models.
So people are using fiction.
Speaker 1: Assuming that scientific models
are fictions or useful
instruments to just get rid
of the metaphysical questions
about the nature of fiction models
or the relationship with reality.
So to make a long.
Story short,
this fictional interpretation doesn't
lead to any sort of metaphysical
conclusion
about the nature of consciousness.
Or the nature of mind
or anything of that sort.
So this brings us.
To the last interpretation of.
Speaker 1: Miracle for accurate.
And it comes in terms of.
Speaker 1: Over time or anything that I don't.
Have much time.
I try to wrap it up quickly.
So the final.
Speaker 1: Interpretation is.
Speaker 1: To interpret more.
Like it's in terms
of. Mathematical models.
And I think.
That there is. Good textual growth.
So it is to at least to my.
Speaker 1: Mind, to some extent
from for someone who is coming
from a background of of science.
It seems rather.
Obvious that more people than kids
are just mathematical modeling tool.
So there are.
Mathematical.
Tools in the context of.
Bayesian.
Networks to describe to represent the.
Conditional.
Speaker 1: Independence
between internal and external spaces.
And there is.
Speaker 1: Textual evidence for that.
Again, I have my part of that
which indicates that
there.
Enterprise aims to describe a construct
from information theory.
And mathematical.
Physics that helps them to.
Speaker 1: Define the.
Properties of living system
and their cognition
and give them some sort of
meaningful interpretation.
Speaker 1: By invoking a mathematical.
Object that could be used to consolidate
this interpretation. So
and the use of.
So I think
that there is some sort of enlightenment.
Speaker 1: Insight.
In modern.
Philosophy of science.
Speaker 1: In the wake of.
For example, postfix tubes
and both of them for us and in 1960s
and 1970s.
So people's.
Attention has been drawn to.
Speaker 1: The importance.
Of mathematical models, theory
and model theory and that sort of.
Speaker 1: Stuff.
For modeling
natural phenomena.
So when doing science scientists.
Speaker 1: The right of model are in some sense
the rise of model science.
Has. Been the result of being wonky,
which is sort of
mathematical approaches that.
Allow.
Us to.
Speaker 1: Represent
and model natural phenomena of, you know.
Speaker 1: Precision and vigor and rigor.
But the thing is
that if we assume that my career.
Models are some sort of mathematical.
Tools.
Speaker 1: That can be used
to represent the features of reality.
Speaker 1: The thing is that we couldn't develop
any sort of metaphysical conclusion.
About the nature of reality
on the basis of application
of these mathematical tools.
Look, if we assume that Markov.
Blankets are.
Mathematical.
Tools, and if we want to identify
their nature with the nature of reality,
the only conclusion that follows
is that the reality
of some sort of mathematical object
is some sort of measurement.
Quite an interesting thing,
as I will argue.
Precisely the.
Speaker 1: Same sort of confusion that.
That.
Speaker 1: Priesthood and colleagues.
Reached in the end of their.
Paper. So
at some.
Speaker 1: Sense they are saying that they are.
In they intend. To defend some sort
of reductive materialist
or reductive physical objects.
But what happens. Is.
That they come to the.
Conclusion that.
Because these two ways of.
Describing the nature of reality,
this division on the basis
of more coherence
of the two external and internal spaces.
Because none of these
interpretations.
Speaker 1: No one of these geometries
that they develop, none of this intrinsic
and extrinsic perspective could be.
Supported under the assumption
that neither.
Perspective is pre.
Speaker 1: Related. One would.
Have to conclude
that reality is fundamentally.
Ontologically. Neutral.
And they assume that by.
Speaker 1: Speaking ontological, neutral
or neutral nature of reality, they are.
Trying to be open the.
Speaker 1: Mathematical nature of Markov
and blankets Markov.
Models to
make concession on some sort of.
Monism which identifies
the nature of reality as neither
physical nor mental.
But I would say that it.
Would be quite a lot to read into the use
of mathematical models.
So of course.
Mathematical tools
are neither in substance.
Speaker 1: Or neither. Mental nor physical.
If you are not an idealist or a realist,
especially if you are
a physical historian
of mathematical entities.
Speaker 1: But it doesn't follow.
That the target systems
that could be used.
Speaker 1: On the basis.
Of using these mathematical tools.
So the reality, the target system
that is going to be used by invoking
these sort of mathematical tools.
Speaker 1: Itself is neither mental nor physical.
So it is the conclusion of paper.
And for coming to that conclusion,
I have.
Also discussed some sort of a structure.
Here is interpretation of the paper.
Again, this is.
About the relation between.
Speaker 1: Mathematical tools and
the physical reality that they represent.
Speaker 1: So again, Freestone and colleagues
would be happy.
Speaker 1: To make conversation on some sort
of a structure or the earnings
interpretation of the remarkably unknown.
Exam but in the context.
Of this structure, realism to a structure
really as.
Some of the.
Leading a structure
such as the Steven French and.
Again leading men are.
Speaker 1: Quite explicit about what is clear.
They do not make their ontological.
Commitments on the basis of the
mathematical framework that they use.
Speaker 1: So they use mathematical.
Framework, they use model theory,
they use theory because they believe that
the semantic framework model to approach
or strategic approach science.
Speaker 1: Mirrors.
Its structure
use, loyalty's on its sleeves.
But it doesn't mean that ontology itself.
Could be read off program, the features
of these mathematical tools that they do.
So they are very clear
that the job of the measurement.
Tool is that the use of.
Speaker 1: Orthodoxies.
Structurally
and these are using mathematical tools
such as theory
and model, theory and category theory.
But they are very.
Clear that the job of these mathematical
tools is mainly representation.
It is not constitutional,
it is not ontological.
On the other hand,
it is the physical reality
that is supposed to be represented.
That. Has some sort of.
Ontological. Constitution or rule.
And with regard to Mark
and is if you want to.
Speaker 1: Derive any sort.
Of the use of the mere application
of more codified models does.
Speaker 1: Not lead to any sort of
metaphysical conclusion.
Because more and more.
Speaker 1: Those arguments
remained representational.
So they.
Help.
Us to represent features of the reality
that is the target system,
the brain or consciousness or organism
or the environment or whatever.
It doesn't.
So we could not build up on.
Speaker 1: The features of this mathematical
model itself to derive any sort
of ontological or physical contribution
of the features of the target system.
Speaker 1: So thank you very much for listening and
I hope.
That what I said
makes some sense, at least to some of.
You, but although I.
Speaker 1: Could not be completely sure.
So thank you very much.
Awesome.
Thank you for that
fascinating presentation.
We already have
a couple questions in the chat,
so if anyone else wants to ask questions,
we'll have a good amount of time
now just to talk a little bit
and I'll just read down
the questions that were asked in the chat
and a few things I wrote down.
So the first question in the chat was
as far as different styles of modernism
or different threads in the history
and the philosophy of non ism,
how does a Dawkins based mechanism
so thinking about like means biological
or non
biological memetics
that's kind of a Dawkins mechanism,
how does that parallel or overlap
with for Estonian modernism?
So in other words, how does for instance
modernism or the Markova and Mon ism
relate or overlap with other approaches
to modernist type theories?
Speaker 1: Oh, well,
thank you very much for the question.
I mean, I'm not very knowledgeable
about the different types of Moonies.
Speaker 1: So I know about some quite classical
theories of modernism.
I know a few things about, for example,
or earlier among them, or.
The form of.
Speaker 1: Modernism that has been developed by
Charles Sanders pay per se, aside from,
for example,
the classical forms that are Spinoza.
Out of
so I'm not
very well
versed, I'm not very knowledgeable.
About these kind of go
Keynesian modernism.
Speaker 1: I barely know.
Anything about memes,
and I'm not sure that we could
identify memes
as real ontological entity.
But and I have already.
Speaker 1: Argued this, I have some sort. Of
misgivings about.
Priesthood and views.
Speaker 1: And. Customs version of Mormonism. So
I do not want to give.
A readymade answer.
I would say.
That if Keynesian modernism resembles.
Free Estonian monies with regard
to the fact that it involves memes,
which are,
as far as I can give, some sorts
of surgical tools as features of reality.
It could be liable.
To the same kind of objections
that I have.
Speaker 1: Spirited.
Here against. The.
Free stonier kind of Mormonism.
Thanks for the clear answer.
And I guess the follow up on that is
where do you situate this Markov
and modernism in relationship
to these classical kinds of modernism
that you just mentioned?
Is that discussed in the paper or what?
How would you frame that.
So all right.
Thank you very much.
Again, it is it is
a fascinating question.
Speaker 1: So before this,
I have developed some sort of a structure
or these theories of.
Consciousness, too, that have been.
Speaker 1: Basically based.
So my own.
Speaker 1: Approach to free energy
principle is associated
with some sort of a structure
you need them to.
So, again, I myself have.
Speaker 1: Invoked some source of my time.
I suppose structure embodied information,
all the structures.
To describe the structure of the.
Mind and consciousness. And my. Basic.
Argumentation
there was that this structure.
Sort.
Of underpinned the diversity
between different forms of consciousness
in terms of free energy principle.
Georg.
Nordhaus, resting state activity theory,
for example, integrated information
theory of consciousness.
Speaker 1: So I myself there are some.
Speaker 1: Sort of a stretch area
with regard to the metaphysical
that speaks with regard to so
by moon is them specifically as some sort
of metaphysic called approach.
And also I have been.
Speaker 1: Very cautious with regard
to stating a metaphysical existence.
Speaker 1: So at the very, you know.
Speaker 1: The structure of ideas and that's
how we have invented was some sort
of epistemic
historical area is it was still realism.
Speaker 1: But it was the piece of work
in the sense
that I was ready to make commitments.
To the fact that to the extent that
our scientific or scientific knowledge
is informing us the future of reality,
the structure
of what we could as many.
Assertions.
Speaker 1: About the nature of reality itself.
So whether it is the structure
of the world or whether it is.
The same.
As the
the self, same as thought that is there
or there are several kind of substances.
So I, I professed.
Speaker 1: Agnosticism
towards the future as a reality.
And so, so the version of a structure
that I defended was epistemic and I
have no stance on.
Speaker 1: The. Nature of reality.
And so there are mornings
or two of these times or any other.
Speaker 1: Kind of approach.
Speaker 1: That's really interesting
seems pretty fair to be agnostic
on the ultimate structure of reality.
And you had a quote on one of the slides
that the structural realism
is taking the pressure off
of strong ontological commitments.
So how would you summarize this
kind of best of both worlds
structural realism approach?
Are we just is it a buffet
or are we just taking what we like
or what are we committing to
with epistemic structural realism?
Very, very surreal. So
I I think that
it is partly an issue of motivations.
So when it's stating the structural
realism, for.
Example, people such as.
Speaker 1: John Gore or built utopian arguments.
From history of science to argue that.
So it takes the.
Pressure off
ontological pressure in the sense
that it doesn't make commitments
to the intrinsic nature of entities,
it doesn't make commitment to objects.
It is committed.
Mainly to the relations so.
And I think that I'm defending.
Speaker 1: Some sort of epistemic form
of historical realism because as I say,
it is completely agnostic
about the future reality itself.
So for example, people
such as John Morel.
Are defending the structuralism.
On the basis of history of science
has been very clear examples,
for example,
from the history of optics to show
that there is some sort of continuity
between theories of optics,
although it seems that there are cultural
scholarship in the history of science.
So some of the term
sort of some of the critical entities
that were supposed to be the subject
of ontological commitments before. Or.
Eliminate from or ontology today.
But it seems that there is some sort of
continuity at the level of the structure
of the theories, at the level of form.
Speaker 1: So they are not making comment in.
This they are indeed
taking ontological pressure from
their theory, although
there are other forms of, for example,
anti construction realism.
Speaker 1: Which itself comes in.
Various stripes.
For example,
James Legrand is defending some social.
And. Humanities
approach to structure.
And I think that for good reasons
from the his
from reason that many particle physics.
Of what
I'm is slightly.
Skeptical that so that sort of structural
realism is taking a sort of.
Speaker 1: In terms of.
Speaker 1: Ontological commitments.
I'm skeptical that. It seems less.
Speaker 1: Cumbersome that.
The orthodox.
Speaker 1: Forms of scientific realism I'm sure.
Speaker 1: That if there is a. Perfect.
Match between the need to eliminate.
Speaker 1: The structural realism and.
Speaker 1: What we know about what.
Model of physics,
many particle physics is representing
all of the features of the. World.
But with regard to.
Metaphysics, for example, or to construct
variation claims that all that
there is is a structure
which is a strong metaphysical claim.
So it. Eliminates.
Entities objects from the ontology,
which is quite ambitious
and a strong ontological commitment. So
and the thing is that I do not think.
Speaker 1: That the version of a structural realism
that Chris Dodd
and colleagues have defended is epistemic
because they are defending
some sort of metaphysical cases or monies
that we some sort of metaphysical text.
So although the structural realism
was supposed to be
ontologically.
Speaker 1: Modest in the.
Sense that at.
Least, for example, Warhol's version
doesn't make commitment.
To the nature of
the word.
Itself, the metaphysical versions
of a structure such as games labeling.
Or or including.
Speaker 1: Or harboring a strong metaphysical tests
that will the features of reality
that they are.
Claiming to.
Be completely structural.
Speaker 1: And I think that in this sense.
Markov in Monism
that is defined by Christopher
and others, is not metaphysically modest
at all.
And I think that this is one reason
I do that.
And thank you.
Speaker 1: Very much
for bringing this point to my attention.
I didn't know this point
clearly in the paper because I didn't.
Spend. Many time
to discuss the structural issues.
And this is.
What I think that nor.
That I look at it from.
Here, I can see that it could be the main
motive behind my mind that encouraged.
Me to be a bit critical
of all this formal modernism that is
presented in this paper,
wonderful paper by Freestone Records.
Speaker 1: Cool. Cool response.
Here's another question from the chat
kind of keeping with
this theme of physics and realism
and scientific communities.
That are evolving their models.
You mentioned optics,
so let's think about particle physics.
Cambridge Breaths.
Can the author describe
in his personal belief,
the main difference
between a mathematical Markov
blindness of an electron
when it's behaving as a particle versus
when it's behaving as a wave?
Speaker 1: So how do we think about
quantum mechanics and quantum phenomena
when we're talking about these different
realism ideas?
Speaker 1: But to be quite honest, I have no idea.
I do you think that
this is mainly because of my.
Speaker 1: Ignorance of.
Modern physics, so I have.
Speaker 1: Some general conception of what happens.
Speaker 1: At the level. Of particle physics.
But how to say that in terms of.
More than I can imagine, how could we.
Speaker 1: State that in terms of Markov blanket.
Speaker 1: But I cannot.
See how the distinction is a particle
being in of state or being.
Speaker 1: An entity being.
In a very big state or part of the state.
Could be related to this issue of
Markov models.
I assume that. Most probably are models.
So one thing that I know about Mark
Colvin.
All the models is that they are.
So powerful.
They are such powerful modeling tools
that they could be used almost to want.
Everything. That there is to be.
Speaker 1: Model. But
well, and I
suspect and it is only some sort of.
Wild guess that we.
Could model the behavior of an.
Speaker 1: Entity either in its various states
or in.
Speaker 1: As far as we try.
To provide some sort of probabilistic
representation.
Speaker 1: Of the.
Behavior of the entity to.
Model the conditional.
Speaker 1: Independence
between different states out there.
Speaker 1: We could impose.
Speaker 1: Markov in blanket Markov
blankets to do a lot. Of
I think.
Speaker 1: At the same time,
I miss the main part of.
Speaker 1: The core of the question.
I think
just maybe guessing from the context,
the electron is something
that we might say we might want to say
Ontologically exists, or some might think
it ontologically exists.
Yet it can display this
sort of bimodal behavior
when it can, depending on the double slit
and the context of the observer,
it can be impacted. Yeah. Great.
So, all right.
So how does a more coherent blanket does.
Speaker 1: To. That?
So as I say, this
this kind of approach to.
The behavior of the entities
in many parts of physics
was what motivated people
such as Steven French and James.
They developed forms of a structure.
Yeah.
So it is not
only an issue of an electron.
The thing is.
That they will look at this,
the behavior of entities at the level of
maybe at the fundamental level,
if I don't want to use a fundamental
at the level of many particle physics.
They should do all behavior.
Speaker 1: There is some sort of package
that includes individual objects.
And it is the interpretation,
for example.
Of the.
Electron that allows us to identify
that as some sort of individual objects.
And there is a package that doesn't allow
us to model it as an individual object.
Speaker 1: So there are rules.
So if you have. To conceive of the.
As both individual individual objects
and non.
Individual objects and.
This seems to recall.
What would be your ontology
your model physics and its structure area
is it provides
an answer to that saying that.
Speaker 1: Oh, look, let's.
Speaker 1: Consider the.
Speaker 1: Commonality, let's.
Consider the common structure that.
Speaker 1: Underpin both formulation
and the behavior.
Of electrons, for example,
are restricted in terms of so
our sort of the statistics
that are developed.
From Max.
Both work, for example,
both by studying statistics
and other sorts of statistics.
So I assume that we could also.
Invoke some sort of a Markov blanket
to behavior.
Speaker 1: To, to model the. Behavior of.
Speaker 1: These.
Kind of entities
at the level of so particle physics.
Speaker 1: What does the question.
Mean to indicate
that there would be some.
Speaker 1: Sort of. Ontological. Game to do?
So the thing is that even in philosophy
of physics, the discussion of a.
Speaker 1: Structure area that there would.
Be could invoke some sort of.
Representational.
Mathematical tools or we have to just.
Speaker 1: Rely. On the
geometrical.
Speaker 1: Or physical statement of the situation.
So I think that.
These are sophisticated issues
in the philosophy of physics.
Speaker 1: And hardly an.
Expert in that.
But I'm not very clear.
Speaker 1: What's obvious.
Advantage
is the state of regimentation of a state.
So, so particles in terms of markup
language would do
to the extent that metaphysical instances
all excuse or right or energy.
Cool.
So here are a few general questions,
but what does it mean
to be ontologically neutral?
So that was brought up
and I was just wondering what
what is the alternative or
how could it be charged or not neutral?
What is it that.
Speaker 1: There are several ways
of remaining ontological.
Speaker 1: Neutral. So for example.
Speaker 1: A way that.
We prefer is to, as I say, appropriate
ontological agnosticism
to not make any commitments
about the nature to do. So.
But I do not think that it is.
This sort of ontological neutrality
that is at issue in Christian
colleague's paper.
I think that they want to be
ontologically.
Neutral in the sense that it is.
Speaker 1: Traditional division.
Speaker 1: In the philosophy
of what is being physical.
So between dualism, for example,
physical exam, people
who think that the nature of mind
is physical and people who think that.
Mind.
Or at least mental properties
are different from physical properties.
So I think that
more coma and moaning.
Speaker 1: Wants to be ontologically neutral
in the sense that it doesn't
want to make commitments
to either mentalism
or physical things, that it doesn't
want to identify consciousness.
Speaker 1: Either. In physical terms
or mental terms.
And in this service, it tries is tries
to remind ontological neutral.
Which I think it. Is quite cool.
So as I. Say, I'm a great admirer.
Of this project because I think it is
the first significant attempt
that tries to develop
really or a principle into.
A remarkable.
Metaphysical test.
Speaker 1: And I think that if.
Speaker 1: Relative principle theories.
Could really show.
Speaker 1: That the theory could support
or could be construed along
the lines of a neutral moon is to show
that it's really so persistence
that doesn't come close.
Speaker 1: Either. To
conceiving of the nature of
mind as a mental state or as a mental
as for mental properties or as physical.
It will be a real.
Achievement, I think.
But at the same time,
I think that just depending
on the mathematical framework of Markov.
Speaker 1: Model doesn't provide sufficient courage
for doing that.
It doesn't provide a sufficient basis
for boosting
the well-supported form of Mormonism.
Very cool.
So it sounds like
there is the eternal debate
of whether mind leads to matter
or matter leads to mind
is there one type of thing,
two kinds of things?
And it would be awesome for free energy
principle to step into that gap.
But what we've seen so far
with the interpretation
of the mathematical construct
of the mark of blanket does not
adequately resolve
this metaphysical question.
So what kind of analysis or research
or measurements or calculation?
I mean, I'm a scientist,
so I'm thinking about measurement
in experiments, but as a philosopher,
what would reduce our uncertainty
about where the step fits into all of us?
So for
for it to be occurring with philosopher
to try to prescribe or endorse
anything to the scientist?
The thing. Is that I feel that
the cool thing about Corrective.
Services and neurosciences is that I.
Speaker 1: Think that.
Speaker 1: Philosophical ideas could really be
useful to scientists in this field.
Speaker 1: But the nature of. This collaboration.
The nature of what.
Happens here is so sophisticated that.
One can hardly so so I'm told that.
Prediction is pretty hard,
especially about the future.
So I couldn't have any idea or.
Any prescription or.
What can we do to break to.
Make this approach more. Fruitful?
The only thing that we could say
we could do.
Is precisely the thing that we are doing.
Just trying our. Best and collaborating.
So I think. That is why this
is a cool idea, because.
Speaker 1: It. Allows people from different
backgrounds
come and share their ideas
and we will see whether anything
significant
will emerge from all of that or not.
Speaker 1: But I think that this is.
The only thing that you could. Do.
But it does mean the only.
Thing that we have been doing
for quite a while and those for.
Whom very it's almost like there's
the mind matter dualism and then there's
the science and the humanities
or science and philosophy.
And so is one going to envelop the other?
Is there really only one
and the other one is kind of a subfield.
And instead of playing
into that dichotomized debate,
which is polarized, it's almost like
we're taking it on to logically neutral
stance here and highlighting
the importance of coming together
across different contexts
and having that conversation.
Speaker 1: So my question on that would be
let's just say
that there were somebody who were curious
and wanted to jump in to learn more
what kind of research or skills
or mentorship
might help this person on their journey,
whether they're,
you know, from a philosophical side
or from a scientific side.
What do you think would be some key
tips for
somebody
who's just starting on their journey?
Speaker 1: Oh, well,
the best thing that I've heard about.
The relationship between two different
disciplines coming from a student
who's a structuralist
and also a wise philosopher, also saying
that metaphysics is best
for which science and science is best.
Then of I don't.
Want to say that informed by metaphysics,
but at least taking some metaphysical
insight into consideration.
Speaker 1: So but on the other hand,
I think that the nature of.
Scientific and academic work these days.
Is so.
So in other.
Words, the scientific activity is so
compartmentalized these days.
People are doing
their different walks in different
disciplines in their own labs and.
Speaker 1: Of the nature.
Speaker 1: Of the problem is so hard that they have
to spend all of their time.
On. A specific problem. So
I can hardly also provide any advice of
what kind. Of mentorship suits.
Anyone who wants to work hard or.
Do some excellent job
afraid or depressed.
But what I can say that
what's very interesting
about creative principle is that it.
Speaker 1: Seems to provide.
Speaker 1: At least some. Of.
Virtues for for a discourse,
some space, for a discourse
between scientists and philosophers.
Speaker 1: So it seems that sort of some of the
good.
Sciences, such as, for example, the max,
but are arms or
objects constant
or freestone himself or scientist or
or completely interested in philosophical
discussions of what's happening.
Speaker 1: And it seems that what's even more.
Wonderful, it seems this.
Speaker 1: Philosophical.
Speaker 1: Discussion or affecting the nature
of their work sources.
I think that is something
that you can hardly observe.
For example. In
aged of the.
Our theories of physics, these days,
I don't know whether
the great physicist are studying
philosophy for their amusement or not.
Speaker 1: But I.
Doubt that they are in these sorts of
constructive
relationship with philosophers. So
I think that just kind of in.
The nature of creativity creates,
you felt itself is quite unique
to the cage, or he brings different
disciplines, we've got
different ideas
from different disciplines together.
Speaker 1: So I have.
No clear idea about the mentorship
or any kind of a schedule or program.
But I can say that people
who are interested in creativity,
principle and study.
That our approach has.
To get a wider scope.
Speaker 1: We invite. Intellectual school. We.
We insights from a number of different
disciplines biology,
computational neuroscience,
cognitive psychology, philosophy of mind,
philosophy of biology,
and that sort of thing.
So it seems to
cognitive discipline as it is
theory.
Principle for response.
And I liked how you grounded the paper
and the presentation in the history
and the philosophy of science,
because it is a community
that enacts the conversation
around the ideas.
And then when there is not
a healthy dialog, it's kind of like
the philosophers are sweeping up
after the scientists or vice versa,
or they're just sort of spectators
to each other, but then we're almost
moving towards a fruitful
bi directional conversation
that actually, as you're pointing out,
with all the specific people
who are taking this into their research
approach, it actually is something
where the science and the philosophy
are co influencing each other.
So that's very interesting and special.
It's almost like it's
such a big scientific idea
and so challenging that we know
that we need multiple expertizes,
we know that we're going to need to be
working on it together for a long time
and then that helps set the stage
for something
that might surprise people because it's
not just coming from their camp.
Speaker 1: So we have history
and philosophy, science.
And then I guess another
thread is math, mathematics.
Markov Blankets, as you pointed out,
came from Perl
in the 1988 work and has been developed
a lot subsequently.
Where does set or category theory
come into this oh.
Whoa oh, whoa.
Very good question.
So I think that
in some sense
it depends on your view of your.
Perspective on mathematics.
So if you are set towards a foundation
of using mathematic
if you are a mathematician who.
Who. Prays
to the God of surgery
every night in his long years,
you naturally think that every kind
of mathematical theory is coming
is based on surgery
and surgery has a general condition
or there are other people who are ready
to give this rule to the category theory.
Speaker 1: But for me, because my engagement.
Speaker 1: With these ideas
come from a background of structure.
Of realism,
the main thing is that
and it has been.
Going to the wonderful work. So
suits, perfect suits and that for us.
And then philosophers of science came.
To rational.
Reconstruction have been the program
from the very beginning
of the history of philosophy of science.
Speaker 1: So philosophers and again, it is why.
Speaker 1: We the principle is so interesting for me
because of its great unification school.
Speaker 1: And there have been philosophers.
Of things and there are some philosophers
outsiders who think that the main job
of philosophy of science is to form
some ideas about unification of sciences.
And in order
to bring about this unification and
philosophers thought of using
logical formal frameworks
for a state regiment and different
theories from different disciplines.
So for example, in physics,
people are using this particular form
of mathematics in biology
when they are using mathematics,
I so they may use a statistical. Of.
Theories
or different forms. Of mathematics.
And they came. To this idea that.
Speaker 1: If we use some form.
Speaker 1: Of logic, so form, for example, theory
model theory.
We could have a cool mathematical.
Framework that allows us to regiment
different theories
from different disciplines
and clarify their relationship together.
Speaker 1: And have a
well-stated.
Clear,
neatly stated
view of what's happened in the war.
Assuming that science provides
a reliable picture of the war, if.
Speaker 1: We could use Model.
T or set theory.
And the thing is this
and I stated.
This view in a book
that has been published by Springer,
according to A Structure of egotism.
I begin to have doubts
about the usefulness.
Or at least realistic.
Impact.
Speaker 1: Of using search theory and model to
or to represent the features of the war.
Speaker 1: So I.
Become a skeptical in the sense
that I hope that this century
and we'll go to frameworks
or to abstract and.
Speaker 1: Even encouragement.
The structure of sciences
into this framework.
We are still. Couldn't account
for scientific representation
because these are.
The set theory.
Speaker 1: And categorically
do not represent the world.
These are scientists
who are representing their work using.
Mathematical models so I try to you
would depart.
Speaker 1: From the usual base
of scientific representation
on the basis of sectarian model theory.
And invoke.
Other sorts of mathematical frameworks
that could provide a better.
Match, a more.
Speaker 1: Congenial tool for accounting
for scientific representation.
If you. Are beginning. To.
Speaker 1: Try. To introduce some sort of
information towards you framework and
not only information towards your claim.
Speaker 1: But embodied.
Information sources framework mean
precisely the same sorts of framework
that Freestone and colleagues
are using in terms of approximate
ways the ideas to regiment
the structure of scientific theories.
Because I came to the idea that those of
us to have a more realistic account,
if you be able to regiment
the structure of theories into this
approximate Bayesian framework,
for example, instead of sectarian models,
we could provide a better understanding
of the relationship between.
Scientific.
Theories which are actually.
Embedded. In the brain of societies.
Or at least in the scientific community
and their target system in the.
Speaker 1: War because of
their.
Centurion model theory or two others
try to take care of the job
of this kind of approximate Bayesians
there is something that that's used
according to our
besides theories is by default
and by the need to break up organism.
Speaker 1: And in these. Theories we could. Have.
Speaker 1: Scientific representations of our
being the relationship
between the organism and its environment.
But it is.
Another story
which is not directly related to this.
My program was obtained the. Year
well it's I think.
Speaker 1: It's super interesting
because this embodied
and enacted relational approach.
We can't leave the scientist
out of the picture.
So it's almost like we remove too much
when we abstract that relationship away.
And then it almost hints towards
that electron question from earlier,
which is, well,
if your ontology or your model is
just an electron, not even the context,
you're going to be lost
because you won't understand
why certain things are happening
to your system of interest.
And so how do we pull back rigorously
and include enough context setting
so that there is an ontology
or a local logic that's making sense?
So it's just cool,
like how the historical thread
in the philosophical thread, it's
not spice or salt on the research,
like just adding it up.
It's actually something
that is, is intertwine us and,
and sets the total scope
of the scientific journey.
So it's like very cool
to hear about that.
So if there's any other questions
and live chat will ask, but yeah, good
yeah.
Speaker 1: Only with regard to the quick Buffalo.
That was the last point
that you mentioned.
So that might be if the contemporary.
Philosophy of science at least
the dominant approach to the search area
is that precisely as you mentioned,
it needs those deep
human beings also of the future
when it comes to presentation.
So there.
Speaker 1: Were a. Bunch of brilliant
philosophers of science
such as Ronald Geary and for example,
Monsignor Cecil,
who you portrayed is still active.
Speaker 1: Who tried to.
Speaker 1: Provide some sort of cognitive.
Model. Of scientific practice.
And so I'll say activity, but for some
reasons I'm not sure what the reason.
It has been pushed.
Aside and it is not the dominant view
of philosophy of science you gain.
Speaker 1: So part of.
Speaker 1: My activity in the philosophy of science
was to bring this sort
of cognitive approach back.
Speaker 1: To the foreground.
And I think that.
Speaker 1: I was fortunate that I bumped up to this
of creator of the principle
and predicted processing because
in order to account
for cognitive models of science.
So we thought sometimes
we do not just going to in
your arms are also philosophers
but on to support
and philosophy of science
about some actual science material.
Speaker 1: And in.
Speaker 1: Order to develop these cognitive models
of studies, cognitive approach
to philosophy of science,
it seems that free
and after principle and predictive coding
are fascinating tools because
they allow us to provide a very cool
and well-supported picture
of the relationship between scientists
who are basically organism
and the community of scientists.
Which could be.
Specified in terms of.
Speaker 1: I don't know, the.
Free energy principle.
Commentaries.
Speaker 1: Of communication
or if we interpret this, the relationship
between community of scientists
underwater. And.
Speaker 1: Their environment more on the other.
And I think that this picture
is much more realistic than the ordinary.
But the both of those
which are of scientific representation
that is questionable is yet cool.
Speaker 1: It's like a
yes and with action and inference.
So philosophy isn't just the armchair.
What does it look like
to be embodied and inactive?
And then perhaps it looks like what is
known by the career name of science?
But we know
that learning and research happens
inside of academia, outside of academia.
So it is a more realistic picture and
here's a related question from the chat.
Speaker 1: Steven asks This ability
to dissolve the internal list
and external list do list position
is a powerful part of Markov and Monism,
thus giving an open dynamical system
the adaptive open boundaries.
Any thoughts on this?
Yeah, I completely agree.
So in the beginning I told that.
I'm a great admirer of Markov.
He wanted to know what I think, that
it is a big step forward, and
this is precisely because of this reason.
Because it goes.
Speaker 1: Beyond the scope of the possibilities
in between.
Go into. So here.
Speaker 1: It is described as some sort of deal
between internal aspects
and spaces. And.
Speaker 1: Precedent causes a lot of force
and energy into developing
these kind of information or geometries.
That's beginning, I think.
Is a wonderful form.
Speaker 1: Of frameworks and models idea.
So this is precisely, in my.
Speaker 1: Opinion, for what it is,
because this is precisely the.
Valuable part of Markov
that he tries to use.
Speaker 1: This kind of scientific model that.
Goes beyond.
This dualism between internal spaces
and external spaces to.
Develop
some sort of of some some sort of.
Speaker 1: Motives of metaphysical cases.
So I completely agree
that this is a brilliant idea.
So the question is what.
Sort of philosophy called argumentation
or scientific argumentation.
Could be offered to support.
This future? So I. Think as as it is.
Speaker 1: The status of this theory
is not strong enough to.
Carry the. Metaphysical weight.
The question is.
As I.
Speaker 1: Said earlier, computer.
Games to comes with the hope.
To provoke the free energy
principle theories to develop these ideas
better a more podium. Monism.
So what sort of.
Philosophical or scientific argumentation
could be offered. To.
Support this insight
that has been mentioned
by the Steven blogs at the core of Markov
and this is the main question.
Awesome.
So just in the last few minutes here,
this paper came out one week ago.
You probably wrote it
several months before,
but what are your next research questions
or what are some exciting ongoing threads
like where do you go?
Let's say someone read this paper. What?
Where are you taking
this frontier of thought?
Speaker 1: All right.
Again, a cool idea.
So as you have already gathered,
my mind is very disordered
just because I'm pursing
several lines of research together.
Speaker 1: So of course, all.
Speaker 1: My research right now
is to develop this kind of model
because to understand
more and more needs them.
Speaker 1: To a defense of.
Modularity is not precisely the source
for glory and regularity,
both at least the source of modularity.
That are defended.
But for example, your quickly
and I think that the model this
that would provide at least.
Some some of grounds for.
Defending a source of modularity.
Speaker 1: This is on the other hand
the other thing.
Is that I feel.
That there is ample room
for metaphysical.
Work on this creator to crazy
creator of the principle
theory of consciousness. So
as you may know, there are already
some more Korean Moonies.
For example offer
some sort of metaphysical reality.
Three Bingo.
Theory of.
Speaker 1: Consciousness.
Speaker 1: But there are also illusionist
course theory.
Speaker 1: All still uses interpretations.
Of a.
Theory of consciousness under free
and your crazy people.
And I think that for. Some reasons.
Speaker 1: None of this provides a quite.
Speaker 1: Good metaphysical interpretation
of the theory of consciousness
under creativity principle.
So I'm developing other theory.
I'm trying to.
Develop.
A theory of consciousness
under the creator of the principle.
Speaker 1: That could because along the line of.
Speaker 1: A strong internationalism,
it is associated with
works of historical work.
So friends
runs out of anti create more recently.
So it is another.
Line of research
that I have in mind to associate.
Speaker 1: This theory of.
Speaker 1: Consciousness
with some sort of intention in order to.
Speaker 1: Interrogate or engage with,
as the paper may indicate, I'm.
Looking for further grounds
for for the results to.
Develop.
Or at least so forth is more coherent.
Is that myself?
So as I say, this paper is just the first
the negative parts
of some sort of argument
that has to be produced by.
Others or.
Myself. So
I. Also am trying to.
Because because I can see the appeal.
Of smart populism.
So I try to find reasonable grounds
for supporting theory.
I'm not sure where does it go, but yeah.
Speaker 1: It's an awesome approach.
A lot of times a critique, it's
almost like Consequentialism
someone says, I don't like your outcome,
so I'm going to look for all the details
or say that it wasn't really supported
conclusion.
And you're almost like saying, Actually,
I do see that goal
or I see the benefits here
and we just need to navigate
in a slightly new way,
but we're going to be learning
and connecting these ideas along the way
because it isn't mapped how we're going
to get to Markov modernism.
And maybe that's
not where we're going, but
we're working towards it.
Speaker 1: I just.
Get excited and.
Quotes you
because it is related to another part.
Of my research
which tries to relate creative principle
to theories of group or group knowledge
to account for, for example,
collective intentionality
on the basis of free energy principles.
So Freeston, our fears have produced
very fascinating theories
of communication and social relation
on the range of principle.
And I think that
I think the this theory could be applied.
To develop the parts
of the pieces of our social kingdom.
There would be wonderful,
wonderful results.
So it is natural.
For me to see this kind of scientific.
Back and.
Forth between different intellectuals
as some sort of collaboration
that's consequential, consequential use,
as you phrased that message
that hopefully leads
to the growth of knowledge in general.
Yes, the individual in the armchair,
it lends one's toward it
lends one's almost to neuro
reductionism and individualism.
But when the person is walking around
and at a conference
and there
they're sharing their experience
and their learning and being surprised
by by friends and colleagues,
then there really is something
that's more like distributed cognition
so all really
look forward to seeing that.
Majid,
thanks so much for this appearance.
This was an epic and special
first guest stream for our lab,
and you're always welcome.
Just let us know
if you have any other topics
that you want to come on stream with you
or colleagues or students or anything.
We're always there to host
and hold the space for this kind of work.
Speaker 1: So again, thanks a lot for the research
and I'm sure everyone
really appreciated hearing it.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much for having me.
And also cool work to do this call back.
To my friends.
So good luck with that often
very well done.
Speaker 1: And thank you very much for having me.
Great. We'll be in touch.
So see you later, Majid.